as these two massive forces approach
each other the black hole will instantly
gain the advantage the white hole will
do its best to prevent the black hole
from overtaking it but unfortunately it
really doesn't stand a chance
that's because the white hole has no
choice but to spit energy at its
opponent
although it was able to defend itself
against everything else in the universe
unfortunately the black hole is its one
true match
the mass the white hole is expelling is
also being turned into energy for the
black hole
this won't be a quick battle either as
the black hole can feed on the Whitehall
for thousands of years
and as it keeps feeding the black hole
is getting larger and larger
and now the black hole is ready for the
finishing blow
it completely swallows the white hole